there were definitely a couple of really
awkward moments in that but if you saw
summarize where what was the actual
thrust of it in essence I think what we
saw there was effectively across the
committee be it conservative or labor
SMP lib Dem MPS I think what you saw was
a sense of uh
incredulity that Boris Johnson was
arguing what he was arguing and I think
Harriet Harman really summed it up
towards the end where she said if I was
going 100 miles per hour and saw the
speedometer say in 100 miles an hour it
would be a bit odd if I said somebody
assured me I wasn't going that fast
because it's what you see with your own
eyes so there's a view within the
committee and it was repeated again and
again and again about how could you say
this was in guidance and rules when
you're at Advance which when we look at
the evidence it doesn't look like that
and then his defense in essence was
these were work events and when social
distancing wasn't observed that was
because the nature of the environment in
number 10 that nooks and crannies the
small rooms in which we operate but
there were moments where as you said
Mark that fell down in evidence one of
them was about the leave-in due he was
particularly questioned on the Lee Kane
his former director of comms leave in
due by Bernard Jenkins the it wasn't
socially distanced a number of people
gathered in a room the Prime Minister
made the defense of well we did do
social distancing
um
we did use social distancing mechanisms
in other parts of the building talking
about screens Etc in other parts of the
building but this social Gathering was
necessary for work events and then
Bernard with the killer question really
was well if you're at the podium a
coronavirus press conference would you
have advised people to have
organizations were allowed to have
unsocially distanced leaving dues know
and then the other thing I thought was
really awkward was the bring your own
bottle party or event in the garden and
he said well yes Lee Kane said the
Optics look bad but it wasn't breaking
the rules that was a bit confusing well
if the Optics are bad isn't it because
it is breaking guidance or rules and he
said to that I thought it was a work
events but I appreciate Jill you said it
the kind of does it pass the look over
the wall test that if a member of public
had looked over the wall what they saw
would be something that they thought
that they were perhaps banned from doing
and I think that was the closest
admission we got to from the former were
prime minister that he acknowledged that
this looked really bad but all the while
he said I didn't think the rules were
broken I was amazed by the fixed penalty
notices I I was amazed to get one myself
and and it was all in the context of
everything we did in Downing Street was
uh related to work essential for work
but there are a couple of moments in
that committee where it was really
uncomfortable for him to to keep arguing
that and I'm not sure the committee was
convinced so was there a so-called
Smoking Gun moment or is it more the
cumulative impact of what he was saying
I don't I didn't see a Smoking Gun in
that way you thought he has been
pinned down but I do think the issues
around some of the evidence that
advisors gave and the way he argued in
Parliament was uncomfortable be it the
Optics of that bring your own
um bottle party or indeed some of the
Reynolds advice his private principal
private secretary saying I don't think
you should go into the commons and say
guidance was followed at all times
because it actually I don't think we can
argue that but his defense again was in
a perfect world it wasn't but in the
round I thought we tried the best we
could so he had a ready defense I think
two issues come out of it is one as I
said the committee uh seem unconvinced I
thought by his evidence but also
he seemed to suggest at the end that if
the committee didn't find in his favor
he would not think that that was a fair
outcome and I think that raises
questions in itself because you know
there has been all these issues around
MP saying it's a kangaroo court and is
it prejudicial against him and he didn't
in that moment where he was going
through that testimony and that that
cross-examination really accept the
legitimacy of the committee which I
think for many MPS watching that they
will feel quite annoyed by that and what
did you feel about his demeanor
throughout that it was well defined he
was quite angry at one time I think he
went through I think he went through
waves where uh he got a bit touchy with
Bernard Jenkin and and began to try and
interrupt him and I think that played
quite badly for Johnson but I think
towards the end he kind of regained
um his concern he was only really in
terms of the answers I thought there was
a two or three moments where he was
stumped one was really it was when the
evidence was put to him about
conflictual advice that he was given
um he also didn't seem to be able uh to
say where this advice had come from
because actually in the documentary
evidence the advice from his director of
Comm Strat Doyle his cabinet secretary
Simon case and then his principal
private secretary Martin Reynolds there
are three pieces of evidence in the
documentation suggesting that they
didn't advise him uh that guidance and
rules were followed at all times and yet
he's saying my advisors did and that's
part of his defense but I do think that
in terms of the presentation I know you
think Jill he came across as sincerely
believe in his argument that was that
was very clear